hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
going to be checking out a trailer for a
movie that I'm actually really looking
forward to it's the Steve Jobs biopic
starring Michael Fassbender called Steve
Jobs let's check this out it's a
one-minute teaser here we go forever two
most significant events of the 20th
century allies win the war and this you
can't write code you are not an engineer
what do you do the musicians play the
instruments I played an orchestra
I spent the garage and invented the
future because I love this you don't
care how much money a person makes you
care what they make but what you make
isn't supposed to be the best part of
you you're the only one who sees the
world the same way I do no one sees the
world the same way you do
Wow cool
really cool I heard that Michael
Fassbender was playing Steve Jobs I
remember that Aaron Sorkin wrote the
screenplay and from my understanding he
said that it's only like the course of
like three scenes I believe like each
act is just the scene I forgot that
danny boyle was doing this I remember
when David Fincher was in the talks for
it Danny Boyle I think is a great choice
for this because he's one of those
directors who's actually popular but
he's known to kind of add his own weird
twist to films like he has his own
flavor his own style and I think it'd be
really cool to see him bring the Steve
Jobs tale to life I did not know Kate
Winslet was in this that makes it that
much better Seth Rogen is in this and
it's cool because Seth Rogen looks like
he's kind of going down that Jonah Hill
path with this whereas it's probably not
like the most super serious performance
but it's serious enough to be considered
a dramatic performance and Jeff Daniels
everyone knows how great that actor is
come on Dumb and Dumber to he was great
but this film seems like it has
everything going for it to make it a
solid Steve Jobs biopic I mean Steve
Jobs to me is one of the most
inspirational people ever I mean I heard
he was kind of a hard person to work
with I heard he was a neat freak very
much anal about everything that he had
to do
but he has such an inspiring story
starts up a company gets fire from his
own company comes back gets hired for
the company again creates Pixar you know
everyone knows about knack everyone
knows about the iPods like the guy was a
[ __ ] genius so he needs a good biopic
i know ashton kutcher played him like I
can't believe I just said the Aston
Kutcher played Steve Jobs how [ __ ]
weird not the choice you think of I love
how the teaser just broke it down and to
like the I Steve Jobs was the definition
of making a comeback Steve Jobs is like
my eras you know inventor I heard he
wasn't the greatest of people but man
was he [ __ ] brilliant and I really
hope they executed a tale that really
has all that of the obstacles yet to
overcome and about going and achieving
the impossible like you know we take
like iPhones and iPods for granted like
if you hold up an iPod just iPod alone
now phones you could store all your
music in there but an iPod like hey you
know instead of having like a bunch of
CD players why don't we just put into
this little box and you can hold all
your songs like that sounds [ __ ]
ridiculous but he [ __ ] Wow rating
time I will definitely be there to watch
Steve Jobs alright guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter and where if we get enough
followers we get product placement
meaning more money for me no benefit for
you does that sound like a deal or what
deep Patel hey man i watch their videos
all the time I really really like them
can I get a shout out you're too awesome
for your reaction really love it post
more okay
deep Patel you can have a shout out deep
Patel is actually what Dev Patel says
whenever he goes inside of a woman's
vagina he goes deep Patel depta tells a
guy from Slumdog Millionaire
most recently featured in chappie in
case you guys don't remember that actor
is but that's what makes the joke funny
his name is Dev Patel deep Patel deep
penetrate you know what [ __ ] you for not
getting the joke